comment berthod commissaire beckerich
c'est pas censé être en congé de
maternité vous crois qu'on est trop con
pour raisonnement 80 et connaît pas le
boulot de gila jamais été sur le terrain
il se retrouve nez à nez avec un mec
découpé en morceaux de la 17 e au xx ou
fait le métier
je suis juriste russe juge d'instruction
présenter les troubles de la mémoire et
me continue d'exercer ou nous elle nous
plaît cette affaire monsieur que je
puisse évoquer la cerise et on sera
comblé démissionne grands dossiers pour
un dossier qui me donne envie qui me
rappelle pourquoi je fais ce métier
juges avocats policiers ils pensaient
avoir vécu le pire
tu m'as déjà mais une fois chez vert
n'aura pas besoin de vous alors ce sera
chacun pour soi mais dans l'univers noir
d'engrenage le répit ne dure jamais bien
longtemps j'ai savoir qui m'a fait ça
sent quand impossible tu as ta pour mes
gars tous les jours j'attends de leur
annoncer que les [ __ ] qui l'ont coupé
en rondelles sont derrière les barreaux
vous avez voulu suite à feu
dites moi vous l'avez fait et je me
battrai pour vous
gilou regarde moi
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas ça
malade tu ferais quoi c'est arrivé à
l'hôtel certain peter king
la série qui a réinventé les codes du
genre enfin de retour création originale
canal+ engrenage nouvelle enquête lundi
18 septembre
[Musique]